[Music]
hey rob i love your podcast
my name is bruce from los angeles and i
was curious
whether you collect anything and if so
what do you collect thanks so much take
care hey bruce thanks for
the question um you know if you've
when people have read my my books or
you know where they've you know listened
to the podcast religiously
you'll know that i'm a kind of a nerd i
mean it may not be
totally the most intuitive thing when
you think about me but i'm a nerd and um
when you ask me what i've what i collect
this is the throwdown
proof when i was a kid the last thing i
really super super collected
were beer cans shocking
but true i was very much into collecting
beer cans now this is in the mid 70s
it was a different time but man if you
could get me a coors
cone top that was like the holy grail
of beer cans there's like a beer cans
association of america i was a member of
total nerd
um i've come a long way i wouldn't dream
of doing it now
in fact i don't even really i don't
drink so um
and then i went through a phase where i
collected antique marbles again
nerd um and
uh i'm trying to think i'm an aficionado
of things which isn't the same as
collecting
i realize um but collecting
i kind of retired but i'm open to
suggestions
um and uh if you call me back and give
me some suggestions i might get back
into it but uh
i hung up my spurs after beer cans and
[Music]
marbles
you